bonsoir et bienvenue dans le
hebdo-politique votre rendez-vous
politique du dimanche soir sur Radio
sensation en association avec TV 78 et
pour l'épisode 232 mon invité ce soir et
le maire de La Verrière Nicolas
Dainville
nos politiques
bonsoir Nicolas Namur bonsoir vous êtes
maire de La Verrière depuis 2020 après
plus de 40 années de gestion communiste
la ville est passée donc à droite bien
que votre majorité municipale se veuille
transpartisane vous faites partie de la
majorité LR au conseil départemental des
Yvelines vous êtes en charge de
l'enseignement supérieur en tant que
vice-président vous êtes également
vice-président de l'agglomération
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui a chargé
de des questions liées à l'emploi alors
ça nous fait beaucoup de sujets à
aborder avec vous ce soir mais
commençons d'abord avec un mot sur
l'actualité nationale et la mobilisation
sur la réforme des retraites entre 1,12
et 2 millions de personnes ont manifesté
à Paris une mobilisation importante
est-ce que selon vous le gouvernement
doit reculer sur cette réforme des
retraites ben écoutez je suis assez
embêté puisque j'ai bien conscience que
le système actuel ne peut pas être durer
sur le long terme on a
les amis des âges qui évoluent on avait
quatre actifs pour un retraité dans les
années 60 on en a 1,7 aujourd'hui donc
on voit bien qu'il faut faire quelque
chose mais je n'ai pas confiance et je
le dis très clairement à ceux qui mènent
la réforme c'est pas du tout la réforme
du siècle comme ça nous était annoncé il
y a quelques temps on devait avoir un
système par point on a que aujourd'hui
une réforme paramétrique on a aussi
je dirais le l'enjeu budgétaire mais le
président de la République est quasiment
responsable de près de 600 milliards de
dettes pour faire une réforme qui
permettrait d'économiser 17 à 20
milliards donc on voit bien qu'il y a
espèce de déséquilibre dans un pays qui
est en plus extrêmement
tendu
archipelisé c'est les phrases de Jérôme
Fourquet avec une inflation galopante
avec des tensions latentes donc je pense
que ce n'est pas vraiment le moment de
faire cette retraite il y a d'autres
urgences notamment pour baisser la
dépense publique il des réformes de fond
donc
je suis je le dis très clairement je
pense qu'il faut revoir le calendrier
revoir la méthode alors les grèves pour
la réforme des retraites impact
notamment les transports alors on le
sait c'est un secteur en crise depuis
plusieurs mois maintenant surtout en
Île-de-France les conditions de trajet
l'attente sont très souvent dénoncées
par les voyageurs de plus le Pass Navigo
a augmenté la verrière et des servi par
les lignes Transilien n etu quelles sont
les retours que vous avez de la part des
usagers bah écoutez forcément des
retours
moyennement satisfaits dès qu'il y a une
augmentation ça impacte le pouvoir
d'achat les
usagers sont bien évidemment peu peu
heureux de CO c'est je partage bien
évidemment cela je pense que l'État
n'écoute pas ce que dit la région la
région dit qu'il faut revoir le système
de financement en augmentant notamment
la contribution des entreprises il y a
eu des promesses qui ont été prises par
l'État il y a maintenant plusieurs
années qui ne sont aujourd'hui pas tenus
donc j'invite l'État à prendre sa part
de responsabilité à revoir la fiscalité
pour éviter ces augmentations qui sont
malheureusement inéluctables si l'État
ne prend pas en main les choses alors
l'attente pour le Grand Paris Express ce
projet qui devrait relier les banlieues
en elles se fait de plus en plus sentir
la ligne 18 elle permettra de relier 51
en Yvelines à l'aéroport d'Orly en
passant par Orsay Massy et Anthony
est-ce que ça va faciliter la vie des de
beaucoup de monde et de beaucoup
divinois oui je le pense c'est important
effectivement d'avoir cette colonne
vertébrale entre le pôle culturel qui
est Versailles le pôle économique qui
est 50 ans en Yvelines et le pôle de
recherche qui est sacré je crois que si
on veut faire réussir cette zone de
Paris Saclay qui doit rayonner dans le
monde avec 15 à 20% de la recherche
française on a besoin effectivement
d'améliorer la desserte et ce projet
ligne 18 le permettra sur 50 ans en
Yvelines à Guy toujours ça permettra
notamment l'éclosion d'un nouveau
quartier ça permettra pour des
territoires comme les noms des reliés à
moins de 20 minutes je crois de de
l'aéroport d'Orly donc je dirais que à
la fois pour 50 ans en Yvelines c'est
une chance mais aussi pour ce territoire
de Paris Saclay ce plateau de Saclay qui
a besoin de cette ligne de métro pour
être relié à la fois au monde de la
culture au monde économique et puis
d'avoir cette cette zone qui permet de
ce rayonnement international une
meilleure desserte donc qui aidera
peut-être aussi les étudiants à choisir
les les Yvelines pour faire leurs études
alors que le covid a permis aux Français
de retrouver le plaisir des grands
espaces et des zones un peu plus rurales
il y a peut-être un coup à jouer dans
les années à venir pour être plus
attractif vous êtes donc vice-président
je l'ai dit au début de cette émission
du conseil départemental des Yvelines en
charge de l'enseignement supérieur alors
dans le classement 2022 de Shanghai
l'université Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et le 22e
établissement français elle 13ème
mondial en termes de sciences de
l'atmosphère et 29e mondiale en sciences
de la Terre alors quelle est
l'importance de l'enseignement pour le
département de l'enseignement supérieur
pour le département des Yvelines et
quels sont les projets qui pour 2023
vous l'avez dit on a une université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin qui qui rayonne
dans le milieu du climat dans le milieu
des mathématiques également tout l'enjeu
c'est de réussir cette fusion avec
l'Université de Paris Saclay qui doit
vraiment rayonner dans le monde et dans
ce fameux classement de Shanghai où les
Français
malheureusement je dirais sont parfois à
la traîne il faut qu'on rayonne aussi et
dans ce monde très compétitif le
rayonnement passe par un regroupement
des talents donc c'est l'ambition de
cette université
paris-saclic il faut qu'on réussisse on
a également le projet d'accueillir tout
un centre de recherche des Mines
ParisTech sur le plateau de Satory à
Versailles le département
investi puissamment près de 100 millions
d'euros pour accueillir près de 300
chercheurs qui vont permettre aussi de
faire rayonner notre département sur
cette thématique de la R&D après on
investit également sur
l'IEP de de Saint-Germain-en-Laye sur
l'IET demande on a tout un tas je dirais
de l'investissement pour avoir cette
offre d'excellence au plus près des
yvelinois de proximité donc on est à la
fois dans l'excellence internationale et
aussi dans une offre de proximité qu'il
faut conserver avec les établissements
que j'ai cité je vais revenir sur la
fusion elle devrait avoir lieu en 2025
donc les universités de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et de Paris
Saclay devrait normalement si tout se
passe bien fusionner quel est l'intérêt
de cette fusion pour le département des
Yvelines
bah écoutez c'est de continuer à
rayonner dans un environnement
international en plein bouleversement
vous avez parlé du classement de
Shanghai aujourd'hui pour attirer les
talents et les talents du monde entier
il faut qu'on soit excellent dans ces
fameux classement internationaux
c'est vrai que les Français souvent je
trouve
s'admire mais il faut maintenant qu'on
se compare et pour pour résister à ce
tsunami international et ce
bouleversement dans le milieu de
l'enseignement supérieur il faut
vraiment qu'on soit fort et pour être
fort il faut qu'on se regroupe et donc
c'est tout l'intérêt je dirais de cette
fusion avec l'Université de Paris Saclay
c'est plutôt que d'avoir une université
de taille modeste dans cet environnement
international il faut qu'on soit
beaucoup plus fort en regroupant les
talents regroupant les compétences sur
cette silicon vallée à la française qui
est donc le plateau de Saclay mais le
plateau de Saclay qui concerne aussi les
Yvelines puisque souvent on parle on a
un prisme trèsessonien mais les qui font
partie intégrante de l'oïen Paris Saclay
qui est censé être silicone vallée à la
française qui doit rayonner dans le
monde avec tous les campus donc on a HEC
on a un certain d'établissement
d'enseignement supérieur qui déménagent
sur sur ce plateau sur cette œillienne
et il faut que l'UVSQ prenne toute sa
part dans ce rayonnement international
donc on fusionnant c'est un projet
compliqué c'est un projet passionnant
mais qui permettra d'être plus fort pour
rayonner dans nos classements
internationaux pour être attractif pour
les meilleurs talents et puis pour pour
exister sur les thématiques d'avenir on
a parlé de l'environnement il y a aussi
la thématique de la médecine avec un
projet d'hôpital nouvelle génération
pour former sur la robotique dans le
milieu de la santé qui est prévu donc
sur Montigny-le-Bretonneux donc il faut
qu'on tire notre épingle du jeu et qu'on
réussisse cette ce projet de fusion
alors on l'a compris donc l'OB
l'objectif de cette future entité sera
d'être une grande marque dans le monde
de l'enseignement supérieur est-ce que
des débats sur le nom ont déjà lieu et
est-ce que il y aura le mot Yvelines
dans dans le projet dans le futur non de
ce projet en pensant le nom c'est
l'université Paris-Saclay c'est vrai que
le je veux dire en terme de marketing
Paris-Saclay et aujourd'hui le nom qui
permet de d'évoquer à la fois cette zone
d'excellence également cette université
effectivement vous avez raison il faut
que les Yvelines et toutes leurs parts
qu'on soit pas oublié reléguer c'est
pour ça qu'on investit je parlais de des
mines parités avec
ces investissements de 100 millions
d'euros pour accueillir près de 300
chercheurs
mais il faut également que le site de
Saint-Quentin et toute sa place dans
cette fusion
c'est tout l'enjeu on est un peu sur une
ligne de crête c'est pas toujours
évident à la fois faut qu'on existe dans
le monde et donc la marque Paris-Saclay
est une marque d'excellence qui rayonne
et tout en permettant aux Yvelines d'y
trouver leur compte et donc il faut
effectivement maintenir sur notre
territoire au plus près des des
habitants des étudiants une offre
d'excellence mais je pense que la marque
Paris-Saclay quand même celle qui
aujourd'hui fait consensus alors pour
accéder à l'enseignement supérieur il
faut passer parcoursup le logiciel de
sélection est d'orientation pour les
lycéens ayant obtenu le bac en 2022 ce
sont 936 000 candidatures qui ont été
traités par le logiciel alors le 18
janvier la procédure a de nouveau été
lancée cette année pour 2023 l'occasion
de renouveler pour certains les
critiques envers cette plateforme qui
serait inégale et qui pénaliserait les
étudiants issus de milieux défavorisés
alors quel est votre sentiment sur cette
plateforme parcoursup est-ce qu'elle
réalise sa mission correctement mais
écoutez comme beaucoup moi j'ai entendu
beaucoup de critiques d'étudiants qui
parfois perdaient une année faute
d'affectation on a cette espèce de
gestion algor rythmique numérisée qui
traite des dossiers plutôt que de
traiter de l'humain donc clairement moi
j'ai une vision assez négative
moi je suis pas contre le principe de
sélection je pense que quand on est une
université il faut pouvoir choisir les
étudiants les plus motivés sur dossier
sur concours sur entretien on le voit
avec Dauphine qui est un peu université
un petit peu atypique mais qui permet de
choisir ses étudiants ce qui donne aussi
une certaine forme d'excellence au
contenu et dans la formation
je pense qu'on devrait s'inspirer de ce
que font d'autres universités je pense
aux États-Unis qui sélectionnent aussi
leurs étudiants qui prennent les plus
motivés ce qui évite aussi beaucoup de
pertes en route on a aujourd'hui une
université française qui accueille
beaucoup d'étudiants qui n'ont pas
toujours le niveau qui n'ont pas
toujours la motivation qui du coup
espèce de fausse promesse avec des
étudiants qui sont dans des parcours qui
ne sont pas toujours adaptés
donc je pense que le système est à
revoir le système de la sélection des
étudiants le système de l'orientation
aussi beaucoup d'étudiants sont orientés
sur des filières qui soignent sont pas
toujours porteuses d'emploi soit qui ne
sont pas toujours adaptés alors à leur
niveau réel
je pense que l'erreur ça a été de
matifier le bac on a un bac aujourd'hui
vous allez venir 90% de taux de réussite
qui parfois laisse croire aux étudiants
qui peuvent réussir dans n'importe
quelle filière ce qui est faux donc je
pense que ce système là de sélection et
vraiment à revoir donc vous en avez
commencé à en parler donc de l'autre
côté certains pensent donc que le niveau
du bac est devenu trop faible vous
l'avez dit donc un taux de réussite de
91,1% de candidats qui étaient admis
donc en 2022 toute filière confondues ça
entraîne de nombreux échecs en première
année de licence et de nombreuses
erreurs d'orientation qui compliquent
par la suite forcément le fonctionnement
des un qui se retrouvent avec de des
élèves supplémentaires à gérer est-ce
qu'il faudrait donc rehausser le niveau
du bac est-ce qu'il est devenu trop
faible aujourd'hui
oui je pense que cet objectif que tout
le monde et le bac est un objectif qui
n'a pas beaucoup de sens je pense que si
on a un prisme français sur les métiers
intellectuels qui est très très prononcé
là où d'autres systèmes je pense au
système suisse je pense au système
allemand mise beaucoup et bien plus tôt
sur la fameuse intelligence de la main
sur les métiers manuels qui permettent
de réussir de manière concrète avec
notamment l'apprentissage ou
l'alternance dans les milieux de
l'entreprise la Suisse a moins de 3% de
chômage et quand on regarde il mise
vraiment sur ces métiers de l'entreprise
dès le plus jeune âge avec des métiers
concrets
plutôt que d'essayer de faire croire aux
gens qu'il n'y a qu'une seule façon de
s'en sortir avec des métiers
intellectuels
qui servent peuvent faire rêver comme ça
mais qui parfois conduisent dans une
voie de garage et ne permet pas de
réussir concrètement dans la vraie vie
en entreprise donc je crois
qu'effectivement il faudrait sortir du
collège unique qui veut enseigner la
même chose de la même manière à des
enfants très différents il faudrait
orienter bien plus tôt comme en
Allemagne en Suisse les élèves qui le
souhaitent vers des métiers plus
concrets plus manuels
et que la réussite passe par d'autres
nobles et qu'effectivement arrêter de
croire qu'il n'y a qu'une seule façon de
réussir qui serait passé par
l'université
il y a des CFA qui cartonnent il y a des
métiers qui aujourd'hui manquent de main
d'oeuvre alors que on en a besoin les
métiers de la plomberie les boulangers
les pâtissiers qui sont des métiers qui
rayonnent en plus on a une un
savoir-faire le métier de la bouche qui
aujourd'hui peine à recruté alors qu'ils
offrent des possibilités de salaire et
je dirais d'épanouissement assez
extraordinaire donc le système français
même s'il y a eu un effort il faut quand
même le reconnaître avec beaucoup
d'apprentis je crois qu'on a eu près de
700 000 apprentis l'année dernière qui
qui ont ce qui a marché mais il faut
qu'on passe à la seconde qu'on débouchés
doubles sur cette dimension
l'apprentissage de l'alternance et des
métiers de l'entreprise alors le débat
sur l'uniforme à l'école j'y viens à
présent il est lui aussi revenu sur la
table en ce début d'année un uniforme
pour les écoliers de la verrière est-ce
que vous vous pensez que c'est une bonne
chose oui moi j'y suis favorable j'y
suis favorable à plus d'un titre moi
j'ai eu la chance à un moment donné dans
ma vie d'étudier un petit peu à
l'étranger j'avais un uniforme c'est
vrai que ça solanise vraiment l'entrée
dans l'école ça habitue aussi l'élève à
faire attention à l'image qu'il renvoie
ça renforce le sentiment d'appartenance
quand on est habillé pareil on se sent
appartenir au même groupe et c'est
important de de renforcer cette cohésion
il y a quelques écoles notamment de la
Fondation espérance banlieue qui ouvre
dans des territoires parfois fragilisés
économiquement socialement des écoles et
il mise sur l'uniforme un petit peu à
l'anglo-saxonne qui sont pas forcément
des uniformes
star cravate c'est parfois un simple
pull avec l'écusson de l'école mais il y
a ce sentiment de fierté d'appartenir à
un établissement
et ce sentiment d'appartenance qui pour
moi est important et puis ça gomme
toutes les inégalités sociales il y a
plus de la question des marques il y a
plus la question des pauvres des riches
on est sur un même pied d'égalité et
donc pour toutes ces raisons j'y suis
extrêmement favorable alors vous vous
avez décidé d'adopter le costume du
Second Empire pour célébrer les mariages
à La Verrière une idée inspirée d'un
ancien mer breton est-ce que vous pouvez
nous raconter un peu cette histoire
écoutez oui c'est vrai que pour moi les
mariages c'est un événement extrêmement
important dans la vie d'un maire dans la
vie des épouses et des moments
inoubliables et donc j'avais envie de me
hisser à la hauteur de leur engagement
qu'un engagement extraordinaire de
personnes qui se disent oui c'est c'est
il y a rien de plus beau dans la vie et
donc pour rendre ce moment encore plus
inoubliable pour montrer que j'avais du
respect pour leur engagement et pour les
époux j'avais envie vraiment de donner
le meilleur de moi-même et je trouve que
un uniforme
voilà qui demande beaucoup d'attention
était une forme de respect que que je
témoignais d'autant plus que c'est un
uniforme en fait qui a été fixé par un
décret impérial de 1852 et se décrit n'a
jamais été abrogé ce qui montre que
l'État a encore pas mal de ménage à
faire dans cet axe mais le décret est
toujours d'actualité il est tombé en
désuétude mais il est toujours présent
et puis à titre d'exemple j'étais aussi
un petit peu marqué par ce contexte
où toutes les traditions se perdent
c'est qu'à l'Assemblée il est de coutume
d'arrivée parfois en tongue ou sans
cravate on fait sortir les petits poils
de de sachemisette bref je suis pas sûr
que ça soit une forme de respect de
l'institution qui est une institution
chargée d'histoire on a des huissiers
qui sont tirés à quatre épingles c'est
un lieu important
souvent moi j'ai eu aussi des fils
d'ouvriers qui qui me disait que leur
père quand il était le week-end il
sortait de l'usine il avait cette
habitude de porter la cravate c'était
aussi une forme de respect envers sa
famille envers ce moment du week-end du
dimanche qui était important et je pense
qu'il faut retrouver aussi c'est
traditions se respectent cette forme
d'élégance française puisque c'est un
uniforme français avec cette coiffe à la
française ce week-end qui permet de
montrer que ce sont des moments
importants et je trouve qu'en tant que
mère c'est important de le dire aussi
aux époux qui vont s'unir le jour du
mariage alors qui dit ce dont empire dit
Napoléon III alors justement cette année
nous commémorons les 150 ans de la mort
de l'empereur décédé en 1873 au
Royaume-Uni alors Premier Président de
la République élu en 1900 en 1848 il est
ensuite celui qui l'a renversé pour
instaurer donc le Second Empire d'abord
autoritaire il est devenu libéral
ensuite on lui doit le droit de grève
l'interdiction de travail le dimanche
mais c'est aussi lui qui instaure en
1853 l'âge du départ légal à la retraite
pour ses fonctionnaires alors 60 ans
après 30 années de service 55 ans pour
ceux qui donc avaient des travaux
pénibles après 25 ans de service alors
vous êtes passionnés vous par cette
période de l'histoire oui c'est une
période passionnante toute la période
aussi du pari d'Osman de ce Paris qui se
métamorphose d'ailleurs aujourd'hui je
ne suis pas sûr qu'on puisse réaliser
tout ce qui a pu faire le baron
Haussmann on a tellement de contraintes
tellement de normes tellement de bâtons
dans les roues ou je pense encore à la
Tour Eiffel qui a pu permettre d'exister
qui fait rayonner la France qui
aujourd'hui serait quand même assez
complexe à construire vu toutes les les
complications que l'État nous impose
c'est une perte de l'histoire
passionnante et aussi cette défaite de
Sedan qui est assez terrible qui a
entraîné d'ailleurs le déménagement du
gouvernement dans le siège de la
préfecture des Yvelines donc qui héberge
aussi le département et donc
avec tiers avec McMahon avec tous ces
présidents qui ont suivi qui ont donc
travaillé dans le bureau du préfet je
crois actuel en tout cas qui ont déplacé
donc le lieu notamment la salle du
conseil au département des Yvelines donc
on a ce lien et puis Napoléon III qui a
aussi inauguré notre gare à la verrière
donc c'est aussi un clin d'oeil dans
cette période qui nous concerne
directement sur le territoire toujours
avec Nicolas Dainville maire de La
Verrière dans l'herbe de politique en
tant que mère vous avez effectué la
traditionnelle cérémonie des vœux
l'occasion donc de faire le bilan de
votre début de mandat et de parler de
l'avenir comment s'est passé ce moment à
la verrière et bien écoutez c'est un
moment chaleureux un moment important ça
faisait près de trois ans qu'on avait
pas pu le célébrer société mes premiers
vœux en tant que premier magistrat de la
ville c'est un moment
de convivialité un moment d'échange un
moment de fierté aussi puisqu'on a pu
évoquer tous les grands projets qui vont
se dérouler dans notre ville notre ville
qui a été choisi je pense qu'on en
parlera pour accueillir la première
étape du Paris-Nice notre ville qui va
accueillir avec 50 ans Yvelines très
prochainement les Jeux Olympiques il y a
quelques mètres seulement de notre
commune notre ville qui se métamorphose
avec des investissements sans précédent
dans tous nos quartiers que ce soit Orly
Park avec des aménagements extérieurs
qui vont améliorer la qualité de vie des
habitants que ce soit le bois de l'étang
avec près de 80 millions
d'investissements avec leur rue l'Agence
nationale de rénovation urbaine pour
changer l'image et donner une nouvelle
dynamique dans le quartier où la gare
qui est en train de se changer de
s'améliorer pour accueillir au mieux les
prêts de 20000 usagers qu'il a
fréquentent quotidiennement donc on a
une ville qui bouge une ville qui avance
une ville qui prend son envol et c'était
une joie de le partager avec les
habitants présents alors vous l'avez dit
la verrière donc en 2023 80 millions
d'euros d'investissement c'est colossal
futur école futur maison de quartier
projet de logement c'est un budget qui
n'a jamais été qu'on n'a jamais vu à La
Verrière c'est vrai qu'on est une petite
commune je dirais que notre gros
investissement dans une marche normale
c'est c'était pas en pleine crèche
l'année dernière c'est un investissement
de 4 à 5 millions mais après on est
entre guillemets un petit peu à sec et
donc là on mobilisant les partenaires ça
permet d'avoir beaucoup plus de faire
beaucoup plus de choses on a les 80
millions que vous évoquez donc sur
l'enru donc du bois de l'étang mais on a
également près de 20 millions d'euros
qui vont être investis sur la gare on a
eu les deux millions d'euros sur Orly
Park grâce au département
dans une ambiance où on se sert plutôt
la ceinture c'est paradoxal un petit peu
exactement c'est vrai que en mobilisant
nos partenaires sur de l'investissement
on peut faire de belles choses c'est
vrai qu'en général les partenaires
gèrent en bon père ou en bonne mère de
famille c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont radins
surtout mais généreux sur l'essentiel et
cette générosité c'est notamment
l'avenir c'est notamment les
investissements je pense donc à la gare
qui en avait bien besoin on avait une
gare totalement à l'abandon désuète
mal
faite notamment pour les personnes à
mobilité réduite donc là on va on a
aménagé cette nouvelle rampe d'accès on
a la nouveau parking ce futur parvis
c'était essentiel on a également
effectivement ce futur quartier des
bécanes avec près de 1400 logements qui
vont arriver dans les 10 15 prochaines
années où il est aussi prévu une école
une maison de quartier donc on avait ici
sur l'avenir c'est vrai qu'on fait très
attention au fonctionnement mais ça nous
permet avec les partenaires d'être
puissamment généreux sur l'essentiel sur
l'investissement un mot sur la sécurité
maintenant c'était l'un de vos
engagements forts lors de votre campagne
en 2020 malheureusement les agressions
continuent comme nous le rapporte actu
78 le 14 janvier un vol avec
intimidation au couteau a eu lieu juste
aux abords de la gare de La Verrière
qu'est-ce a été fait depuis 2020 pour
améliorer la sécurité des habitants
alors beaucoup de choses c'est vrai
qu'on a un contexte avec une gare qui
peut effectivement générer
la venue de mauvaises personnes avec de
mauvaises intentions on a également un
contexte national dans sauvagement
terrible avec une banalisation de la
violence des groupes de plus en plus
jeunes de plus en plus violents qui
semblent manquer de toute forme de
retenue je crois que le chiffre c'est
120 agressions couteaux par jour en
France c'est extrêmement inquiétant et
donc la ville même si elle n'a pas
directement la compétence sécurité prend
le taureau par les cornes on a renforcé
notre équipe municipale
donc on avait un agent on en a
maintenant trois on a ouvert un poste de
police municipale rue de la Mare à La
Verrière on les a dotés de vélo pour
plusieurs proximité également d'armes le
fameux teaser pour toutes les opérations
de contrôle routier qui permettent de
les sécuriser et puis on a ren c'est
cette équipe avec des médiateurs sur le
terrain on a 5 médiateurs dont 4 sont
financés par l'État la mère précédente
malheureusement n'arrivait pas à les
mobiliser nous on a pu en avoir quatre
financé par l'État qui arpente les rues
pour la tranquillité publique et puis on
travaille avec la police nationale et
notamment sur ce futur commissariat
d'agglomération à Élancourt qui devrait
voir le jour là dans les années qui
viennent pour mieux accueillir les
victimes permettre aux policiers de
mieux se coordonner de mieux travailler
et notamment sur l'innovation pour être
plus efficace avec les systèmes de drone
par exemple donc sur tous ces sujets là
on est effectivement très très actifs et
pour finir un mot de cyclisme 2003 sera
aussi synonyme donc deux cyclistes à La
Verrière avec cette date importante le
parinise partira de chez vous une date à
retenir du coup bien sûr c'est le
premier week-end de mars le dimanche 5
mars c'est historique pour une petite
commune comme la nôtre on a beaucoup
pour avoir cet événement je remercie
président du Département d'avoir appuyé
notre candidature
c'est un événement hors normes c'est les
meilleurs cyclistes de la planète c'est
le vainqueur du Tour de France qui sera
chez nous à La Verrière
la première étape se termine au Ménil
Saint-Denis donc les deux villes vont
travailler de concerts pour accueillir
au mieux les milliers de téléspectateurs
qui viendront de loin il y a déjà des
habitants qui arrivent à louer leur
chambre ou leur appartement pour
accueillir des gens qui viennent parfois
de loin notamment de Belgique
ça va être un bazar en termes de
circulation mais ça sera pour la bonne
cause puisque ça va permettre de faire
rayonner la ville il y aura près de 8
millions de téléspectateurs qui seront
placés la verrière sur une carte
corrompt les yeux rivés sur notre
commune et ça permet de mettre en avant
l'incroyable patrimoine historique
culturel sportif de notre commune donc
c'est une fierté sans précédent
rendez-vous donc début mars et puis 50
ans en Yvelines pour suivre à son
histoire avec le cyclisme puisque le
départ de la dernière étape du Tour de
France se fera cette année au Vélodrome
merci beaucoup Nicolas dans les deux
politiques je rappelle que vous êtes le
maire de La Verrière nous on se retrouve
donc bientôt pour une prochaine
interview dans les deux politiques très
bonne soirée à tous sur la des
sensations
[Musique]